When my friend Etgar was a kid growing up in Israel, his mom would tell him a story every night before he went to sleep. But it was almost always a story that she would invent, right then on the spot. Never read him any children's books.
当我的朋友埃特加小时候在以色列长大时，他妈妈每晚临睡前都会给他讲一个故事。但这些故事几乎总是她当时即兴编造的。她从不给他读童书。
And for my mom, the idea of telling us stories from children's books was very much like kind of ordering a pizza instead of making us a dinner. It would mean that she doesn't love us enough.
对我妈妈来说，讲童书里的故事就像是点外卖披萨，而不是亲手做顿晚餐。这意味着她不够爱我们。
So almost every night, it was a custom-made story, with flying camels, or a room that people would walk into and lose the power of speech, and all sorts of other made-up things. But always, Etgar says, the details and the feelings in the stories echoed whatever was going on in Etgar's life that particular day. Etgar's mom did this for Etgar, because her parents had done it for her when she was a little girl in Poland during World War II.
所以几乎每天晚上，都是一个定制的故事，有会飞的骆驼，或者人们一走进某个房间就会失去说话能力，还有各种各样编造的东西。但埃特加说，故事里的细节和情感总是与他当天生活中的经历相呼应。埃特加的母亲这样做，是因为二战期间她还是个波兰小女孩时，她的父母也曾这样对她。
During wartime, the greatest gifts that she got from her parents were the stories that they told her. Because they couldn't give her food. They couldn't give her clothes. They could only tell her stories, and they would put all the love and knowledge and imagination in it. So those stories would be amazing.
在战时，她从父母那里得到的最伟大的礼物就是他们讲给她的故事。因为他们无法给她食物，无法给她衣服，只能讲故事，并将所有的爱、知识和想象力倾注其中。所以那些故事非常棒。
And she would tell me that when they would begin the story, she would be afraid that she would fall asleep in the middle. And then if you fall asleep in the middle, they would never finish the story. So basically, nobody will know how the story ends. So my mom kind of grew up about this idea that a story was kind of a hug or a kiss, or it was just something that you give or share with somebody that you love a lot.
她常告诉我，当他们开始讲故事时，她会担心自己听到一半就睡着了。如果听到一半睡着了，他们就不会再讲完那个故事。所以基本上，没人会知道故事的结局。所以我妈妈长大后，认为讲故事就像是一个拥抱或一个吻，或者仅仅是你与深爱之人分享的东西。
After all that, Etgar grew up to be a short story writer. He's Etgar Keret, has lots of books. There were times that his mother would not invent a story but tell him some story from her past, and he loved those too. As a kid, Etgar had a favorite that he would ask her to retell more than any other story.
在那之后，埃特加长大成为了一名短篇小说作家。他叫埃特加·凯雷特，出版过许多书。有时他母亲不会编新故事，而是讲一些她过去的经历，他也喜欢这些故事。小时候，埃特加最喜欢缠着她重讲其中一个故事。
And this story takes place in the very beginning of the war, escaping the little town they lived in.
这个故事发生在战争刚开始的时候，他们逃离居住的小镇。
Escaping right before the Germans arrived, they're Jews. In the story, Etgar's mom is just five years old. She remembered her mother holding her hand and carrying her baby brother.
他们是犹太人，在德国人赶到之前逃离。故事里，埃特加的妈妈才五岁。她记得母亲牵着她的手，还抱着她还是婴儿的弟弟。
And they're running as fast as they can. You know, they're running and running and running. And all the people of the village or the town are running in front of them. And everybody is much faster than my mother, who's a little child, and her mother, who's carrying a baby. So basically, if it's a race, they are definitely in the last place.
他们拼命地奔跑。他们在跑，一直在跑。村里或镇上的所有人都在他们前面跑。每个人都比我母亲——一个小孩子，和抱着婴儿的母亲——快得多。所以基本上，如果这是一场比赛，他们绝对是最后一名。
Right.
没错。
But my mom kind of sees up ahead of them something that looks like a big grandfather clock that seems to be moving.
但她好像在前方看到一个看起来像大座钟的东西在移动。
Wait, wait. Somebody's carrying a grandfather clock with them as they're fleeing?
等等，等等。有人逃亡时还背着一个大座钟？
Apparently, there was somebody who was carrying it on their back. But for my mom, from a distance, it just looked like a cartoon.
显然，确实有人把它背在背上。但在我母亲看来，从远处看，那就像个卡通片。
Cartoon, because from where they were behind, what she sees is this clock, right, with two feet sticking out underneath it, trudging along, and then an arm poking out on either side.
卡通片，因为从后面看，她看到的就是那个钟，下面露出两只脚，艰难地走着，两边还伸出两只胳膊。
And it kind of amuses her, because, you know, she's a little child. And even when she told me about that many, many years after that, I knew that when she would tell this bit, she would always laugh, you know? And it also amused her that she was in the middle-- like, out of town, running, and she could tell what the time was every second, which is something that is amazing, you know, when you are a five-year-old out in the country to have a clock that will tell you exactly what the time, you don't have to ask, ask your mom. You don't have to ask anybody.
这让她觉得好笑，因为她还是个孩子。即便多年以后她向我提起这件事，我也知道当讲到这一段时她总是会笑。她觉得有趣的是，她在逃亡途中，还能每时每刻知道时间，这对于一个在乡下的五岁孩子来说太神奇了，你不用问妈妈，也不用问任何人。
So for her it's fun. They're fleeing, and she's not feeling danger. She's just like, this is kind of fun.
所以这对她来说很有趣。他们在逃亡，她没有感到危险。她只是觉得这挺好玩的。
Yeah, but when they got closer to the clock, she could start hearing the man gasping, the man who carried this clock on his back. Because apparently the clock was too heavy. And she said that just as they were about to reach him, she saw the man collapse flat on his face with the clock on top of him.
是的，但当他们靠近那个钟时，她能听到那个背着钟的人在喘气，因为那个钟显然太重了。她说就在他们快要追上他时，看到那个人连同钟一起重重地摔在了地上。
Oh, my god.
天哪。
And my mother wanted to stop to check what's with this guy, but her mother said, we have to run. We have to run. We don't have time. And they ran a little bit more, and then her mother said, listen. There's no way we're going to escape the Germans. Our only chance is if we go into a cabbage field-- there was a cabbage field on the side of the road-- and hide there until they pass.
我母亲想停下来看看那个人怎么样了，但她母亲说，我们要跑，我们要跑。我们没时间。他们又跑了一会儿，然后她母亲说，听着，我们不可能逃过德国人。唯一的办法就是走进路边的卷心菜地里躲起来，直到他们过去。
And they went into the cabbage field and lie down, but as soon as they lie down in the field, her baby brother begins crying. And my grandmother, my mom's mother, is afraid that because of the sound, the Germans will come. So she started breastfeeding him.
他们进了卷心菜地躺下，但刚一躺下，她的小弟弟就开始哭。我祖母，也就是我妈的母亲，担心声音会引来德国人。所以她开始喂他母乳。
And my mother said that this moment where her mother breastfeeds her kid brother, she said that the sky were kind of blue. And she was in the field, and she was lying on her back. Everything seemed very normal for a second.
我母亲说，母亲给弟弟喂奶的那一刻，天空是那种蓝色。她躺在田地里，仰望着天空。那一瞬间，一切看起来都很正常。
That's a moment in the story Etgar always loved, even as a little boy, where time kind of stops. And the war stops, and it's his mom, and her mom, and her brother just there.
那是故事里埃特加从小就一直喜欢的一个瞬间，时间仿佛静止了。战争停止了，只有他的母亲、外祖母和舅舅在那里。
And then she saw a shadow. And when she raised her eyes, she saw a German soldier with a rifle in the hand, looking at her and at her mother, who was breastfeeding a baby.
然后她看到一个影子。当她抬起眼，看到一个德国士兵手里拿着步枪，正看着她和正在喂奶的母亲。
And there was something, I guess this kind of strange scene, that affected the soldier. And the soldier basically looked at them, but pretended as if he was looking through them, as if he wasn't seeing them, even though he was very close. And then after a few seconds, he just kind of turned his back and left, as if he was escaping.
我想是这种奇怪的场景触动了那个士兵。他看了看她们，却假装透过她们看向别处，好像没看见她们一样，尽管离得很近。几秒钟后，他转过身走了，就像在逃跑一样。
And I guess from a perspective of five years old, she really, really felt that her family, in this battle, was able to win against the Nazis. You know, her baby brother was cute enough. Her mother was motherly enough. She was sisterly enough, and the skies were blue enough that the soldier suddenly remembered that he had a human side, too, and he couldn't take it. She would talk about the soldier as if he was running away. It wasn't as if he decided to leave.
我想从五岁孩子的视角来看，她真的感觉到她的家庭在这场战役中战胜了纳粹。你知道，她弟弟够可爱，母亲够慈爱，她自己够乖巧，蓝天够晴朗，让那个士兵突然想起了他也有人性的一面，让他无法下手。她谈起那个士兵时，就像是在说他在逃走，而不是决定离开。
Recently, after all these years-- his mom's been dead a little while now-- Etgar has tried to write about her. And when he got to writing this story about the cabbage patch, for the first time, he says, he realized just how close they all came to dying. It really had never hit him before. The way his mother always told the story, it was so from a kid's point of view that there was no sense of danger in it.
最近，这些年后——他母亲已经去世一段时间了——埃特加试图写关于她的故事。当他写到卷心菜地的故事时，他第一次意识到他们离死亡有多近。这从未触动过他。他母亲讲述这个故事的方式总是基于孩子的视角，完全没有危险的感觉。
Even hiding in the field, it seemed like kind of a children's game, like hide and seek. Don't make any noise. When the soldier appears, he's just some man standing there. So it makes the stories tricky to figure out how to tell. You kind of have to choose between describing the reality of the war-- the menacing reality-- and his mother's reality, when she often doesn't understand or notice any of that.
即使躲在田里，也像是一种儿童游戏，比如捉迷藏。别出声。当士兵出现时，他只是站在那里的一个人。所以这些故事很难构思如何去讲。你必须在描述战争的现实——那种充满威胁的现实——和你母亲的现实之间做出选择，而她往往意识不到这些。
Etgar, I should say, writes a lot about his family. He did a whole book about his dad. But he says he's always found it impossible to write about his mom, for a bunch of reasons, actually. Including one big one that has nothing to do with the war at all, but with who she was.
我应该说，埃特加写了很多关于他家人的事。他写过一本关于他父亲的书。但他说他一直觉得写母亲是不可能的，其实有很多原因。包括一个与战争毫无关系的大原因，而是关于她是谁。
The thing about my mother is that it's like-- like, God has many names, right? He's a vengeful God and a merciful God. Then I think that my mom had this kind of thing, that if life is a Hollywood movie, she is Maria in West Side Story. But she's also a Thanos in the Avengers Marvel universe. You know, she's--
关于我母亲的事情就像是……就像上帝有许多名字，对吧？他是复仇之神，也是仁慈之神。我觉得我妈也是这样，如果生活是一部好莱坞电影，她就是《西区故事》里的玛丽亚。但她也是《复仇者联盟》里的灭霸。你知道，她……
And when you would meet her, it would be kind of, I don't know, super energy, super compassion, super aggression. She had these kind of things. If she wanted to say something, she really didn't care what anyone would say.
当你见到她时，会感受到一种超级能量、超级同情心、超级侵略性。她有这些特质。如果她想说点什么，她真的不在乎别人怎么看。
But, for example, when she wanted to listen to Wagner in the times when in Israel you were not supposed to listen to Wagner, who was known as an anti-Semite and who was loved by Nazis, then my mother said, it's my home and that's the music that I like. And I don't care if Nazis like them. They liked apples, too, and I still eat apples. And she didn't care. She just did her own thing.
例如，当她在以色列还不允许听瓦格纳——这位反犹主义者，还是纳粹最爱的作曲家——的时候，我母亲会说，这是我的家，这是我喜欢的音乐。我不在乎纳粹喜不喜欢他。他们也喜欢苹果，但我还是吃苹果。她根本不在乎，她只做自己想做的事。
She was capable of very extreme action. And it was hard not to want to leave out some of the most aggressive parts of her. And it was hard for him to get her across in the way he saw her. And it felt very strange that, you know, he had these books, and he had this whole life as a writer, but he couldn't figure out how to write about his own mom.
她有能力做出非常极端的行动。很难不想去掉她身上一些最具攻击性的部分。他很难按照自己眼中的她来塑造她。奇怪的是，他写了很多书，有作为作家的整个人生，却无法写出自己的母亲。
And then he started drafting these little fragments, short stories that were just like three or four paragraphs long-- tiny stories. And he wrote dozens of them for this museum in Berlin that wanted to collaborate with him. Most of the stories didn't amount to much. They'd start and stop and go nowhere. And crumpled up copies of these incomplete, discarded stories ended up as part of the exhibit that they made.
后来他开始写这些小碎片，也就是三四段长的短篇小说——微型故事。他为柏林一家想与他合作的博物馆写了几十个。大多数故事都没什么意义，开始又结束，不知所云。这些不完整、被废弃的故事副本成了他们展览的一部分。
But the stories that worked, I read them a few months ago. And they just killed me, some of them-- sharp little shards of stories that together captures something complicated about his mom. And Etgar and I decided to try to adapt them here for the radio.
但那些奏效的故事，我几个月前读过。有些真的让我震撼——那些尖锐的小故事碎片，共同捕捉到了关于他母亲的复杂之处。我和埃特加决定尝试将它们改编为广播剧。
So we've done it, and today on our show-- it's "This American Life," by the way, from WBEZ Chicago. I'm Ira Glass. What you're going to hear is this unusual kind of portrait of his mom, told in these quick little stories that Etgar is going to read. It's eight stories in all, plus occasional bits of conversation between him and me.
今天我们做到了，节目是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。你将听到的是一种关于他母亲的不寻常肖像，通过埃特加朗读的这些简短故事呈现。一共八个故事，外加他和我不时的交谈。
His mom-- Orna Keret was her name-- made it to Israel after World War II when she was 14. That's where she lived her life and raised her kids.
他的母亲——奥娜·凯雷特是她的名字——二战结束后在14岁时到了以色列。她在那里度过一生并抚养了孩子。
In the stories, Etgar has changed the name of one little boy who gets beaten up by another boy, because he didn't want to embarrass the guy today. Etgar's wife, Shira, and his son, Lev, show up in a story. And we'll start with this.
在这些故事中，埃特加更改了一个被欺负的小男孩的名字，因为他不想让那个人在今天感到尴尬。埃特加的妻子希拉和儿子列夫出现在了一个故事里。我们先从这个开始。
Story number one, "Bedtime Story." The very first time my mother told me about her father, I was in kindergarten. I remember lying under the covers in my pajamas, while Mom sat on the edge of my bed and relayed the story with pride.
第一个故事，《睡前故事》。母亲第一次向我讲述她父亲的故事时，我还在上幼儿园。我记得我穿着睡衣躺在被子里，母亲坐在床边，自豪地讲述着。
Soon after the Germans occupied Poland, she told me, one of my mother's non-Jewish neighbors began collaborating with the Nazis. He was a short man with black hair and a large nose. As my mother said, he looked like a caricature of a Jew. And he took advantage of this to pose as one, which allowed him to uncover the hiding places used by his Jewish neighbors and turn them in. After the Germans forced all the Jews to move to the Warsaw ghetto, Mom and their family no longer saw this neighbor, although they continued to hear horrific stories about his informing on people.
她说，德国占领波兰后不久，母亲的一位非犹太邻居开始与纳粹合作。他是个身材矮小、黑发大鼻子的男人。正如我母亲所说，他看起来就像犹太人的讽刺漫画。他利用这一点假装成犹太人，从而揭发他犹太邻居的藏身处并将他们送进集中营。德国人强迫所有犹太人迁往华沙犹太区后，母亲和家人就没再见过这个邻居，尽管他们继续听到关于他告密的可怕故事。
One morning, my mother and her father walked out of the ghetto with a simple plan. They would buy a loaf of bread on the black market, sell individual slices in the ghetto to cover the costs, and keep a couple of pieces for the family.
一天早上，母亲和父亲带着一个简单的计划走出了犹太区。他们想在黑市买一条面包，在区内把面包切片卖掉以支付成本，并为家里留下一两片。
They snuck out and walked down the streets of Warsaw without wearing the yellow stars that all Jews had to wear. This was extremely dangerous, but since her father was blond with blue eyes, and she was fair haired, too, they hoped they wouldn't raise any suspicion.
他们偷偷溜出来，走在华沙街头，没有戴所有犹太人都必须佩戴的黄色星章。这极其危险，但因为她父亲是金发蓝眼，她也是浅色头发，他们希望不会引起怀疑。
Unfortunately, in the crowded town square, they ran into their old neighbor, the informant, who didn't think twice before grabbing my grandfather by the shirt collar and yelling, "Jews! Jews!" My grandfather tried to break free, but he realized that even if he could, they would instantly be surrounded by passersby, who would never let them escape.
不幸的是，在拥挤的镇广场上，他们遇到了那个老邻居——那个告密者，他毫不犹豫地抓住了我外祖父的衣领大喊：“犹太人！犹太人！”我外祖父试图挣脱，但他意识到，即便成功了，他们也会立刻被路人包围，他们绝无逃脱可能。
He looked at my mother and gave her a wink meant to reassure her, or at least to make sure she knew that, even in this terrifying moment, he was thinking only of her. Then he grabbed the neighbor by his collar and shouted, "Jew! Jew! I caught a Jew."
他看着我母亲，给了她一个暗示安慰的眨眼，或者至少确保她知道，即使在这种可怕的时刻，他心里想的也只有她。然后他抓住了邻居的衣领大喊：“犹太人！犹太人！我抓到一个犹太人。”
The crowd looked on in confusion at the two men, my tall, fair-haired grandfather and the short, black-haired neighbor, who looked, according to my mother's description, a bit like me, clutching each other's clothes and screeching, "Jew!" Within seconds, a few people fell on the neighbor, pinned him to the ground, and kicked him in the head and body until he was dead.
人群困惑地看着这两个男人，我那高大白皙的外祖父和那个长得有点像我——正如我母亲描述的——矮小黑发的邻居，互相抓着对方的衣服尖叫：“犹太人！”几秒钟内，几个人扑向那个邻居，把他按在地上，踢他的头和身体，直到他被打死。
And that was your grandfather, declared mom with a smile, and stood up. Before leaving my room, she leaned over, kissed my forehead, and said, sweet dreams.
“这就是你的外祖父，”母亲微笑着宣布，然后站起身。离开房间前，她俯身吻了吻我的前额，说：“做个好梦。”
Story number two-- "Razor." When I was a child, my mother hugged me all the time. All mothers hug their kids a lot, I know. But my mother hugged me more than a lot. I liked it. But over time, I began to notice that when she touched me, it was always with the back of her hand, never the palm.
第二个故事，《剃须刀》。小时候，母亲经常拥抱我。我知道所有母亲都会多拥抱孩子，但我母亲抱我抱得太多了。我很喜欢。但随着时间的推移，我开始注意到，当她抚摸我时，总是用手背，从不用手掌。
One evening at bedtime, my mom finished telling me a story, and then stroked my face with the back of her hand. "Mom," I asked her, "how come all the other moms touch like this?" I demonstrated a caress with the palm of my hand. "And you're the only one who touches like this." I demonstrated again with the back of my hand.
一天晚上睡觉前，妈妈讲完故事，又用手背抚摸我的脸。“妈，”我问她，“为什么别的妈妈都这样摸孩子？”我演示了一个手掌的抚摸。“只有你总是这样摸。”我再次演示了手背的触摸。
My mother smiled and kissed me on the forehead. "When I was little," she said, "I didn't have a home like you do, only an orphanage. And the people there, some of them, didn't always want to be good to me. So to be on the safe side, I stuck a piece of gum to the palm of my hand, and I lodged a razor blade in the gum."
母亲微笑着亲吻我的前额。“我小时候，”她说，“没有像你这样的家，只有孤儿院。那里的人，有些人并不总是对我好。为了安全起见，我在手掌上贴了一块口香糖，并在口香糖里藏了一片剃须刀片。”
She showed me how she stuck the gum to her hand, and then inserted an imaginary blade into that invisible gum. When she finished, she held the back of her hand to my face and caressed me gently. "This," she whispered, "is how I touch the people I liked. And this--" she let the palm of her hand hover millimeters from my face without touching it-- "is how I touched the ones I didn't like so much."
她给我看了她如何把口香糖粘在手上，又如何在那无形的口香糖里插入虚构的刀片。讲完后，她用手背轻轻抚摸我的脸。“这，”她低声说，“是我触摸我喜欢的人的方式。”然后她让手掌在离我脸几毫米的地方悬停，并不触碰。“这就是我触摸那些不太喜欢的人的方式。”
The palm of mom's hand was so close to my face that I could feel its warmth. The blade didn't touch me, but I knew it was there. Palm of the hand, back of the hand-- until that evening, I never knew they were so different.
妈妈的手掌离我的脸很近，我能感受到它的温暖。刀片并没有触碰我，但我知道它就在那里。手掌，手背——直到那天晚上，我才知道它们有如此大的区别。
Etgar?
埃特加？
Yeah.
在。
You've told me that one of the things you want to be careful about is you don't want to overemphasize your mom's experience in the war. Explain that. Explain why.
你说过你不想过多强调你母亲在战争中的经历。解释一下。解释原因。
Well, you know, I think that there was something about my parents that they felt at the moment that they were seen as Holocaust survivors. They were kind of losing something at this moment. They became less of an individual and more of, I don't know, a symbol. My parents really, really disliked that.
嗯，你知道，我觉得我的父母在那个时刻感觉，当他们被视为大屠杀幸存者时，他们失去了一些东西。他们变得不再是个体，而成了某种象征。我的父母非常非常讨厌这一点。
I felt for my mom that the moment that she was seen as a Holocaust survivor, it would be a little bit like a wild horse, that it was as if the Nazis had branded her. She can't take this thing off her, you know? But the moment that she could be this funny, redheaded woman who reads a lot, and loves to dance, and who had happened to be in the Holocaust, this was her victory.
对于我母亲，我感到当她被视为大屠杀幸存者时，就像一匹野马被纳粹烙上了烙印。她无法摆脱这个东西，你知道吗？但当她能成为那个爱读书、爱跳舞、碰巧经历过大屠杀的红发幽默女人时，这才是她的胜利。
OK. So with that in mind, maybe we should still summarize very quickly what happened during the war, just to give listeners a general sense. I know her family died. Did she end up in a concentration camp?
好的。那考虑到这一点，也许我们还是快速总结一下战争期间发生了什么，给听众一个大概的了解。我知道她的家人去世了。她最终进了集中营吗？
No. My mom was with her parents in the Warsaw ghetto. And later, they were transferred to another ghetto. Coming to the end of the war, she was totally on her own, and kind of running from one hiding place to another, trying to get food from where she could.
不。我妈和父母在华沙犹太区。后来他们被转移到另一个隔都。战争快结束时，她完全孤身一人，从一个藏身处跑到另一个藏身处，努力寻找食物。
In hiding?
在躲藏？
No. My mother was never in hiding. It's like the way that she survived was more kind of mingling with the Polish, pretending to be a non-Jew. And my mom told me that during the war, it was much easier for children to move around and to smuggle things than grownups, because usually they wouldn't ask them for ID. And it would be more difficult to differentiate them, especially my mom, that they didn't look very Jewish.
不，我母亲从未真正躲藏过。她生存的方式更像是混在波兰人中间，假装成非犹太人。我妈告诉我，战争期间，孩子比大人更容易移动和走私东西，因为通常没人会查他们的身份证。而且很难区分他们，特别是像我妈这样，看起来不太像犹太人。
And she was not only fluent with Polish as a first language, and not with Yiddish like many other Jews. But she spoke fluent German.
她不仅第一语言就是波兰语，不像其他许多犹太人说意第绪语，她还能说流利的德语。
How did she speak German that young?
她那么小怎么会说德语的？
When the war started, the first thing her father did was to teach her German. And he said to her that the moment you can communicate with people, it makes it more difficult for them to dehumanize you. He felt that this would be something that could save her life.
战争刚开始时，她父亲做的第一件事就是教她德语。他说，只要你能和人沟通，就让他们更难把你非人化。他觉得这能救她的命。
Yeah, you told me a story about her on a bridge. Tell that story.
是的，你讲过一个她在桥上的故事。讲讲那个故事。
There is more than one, but I'll tell the one that I like, and if you don't like it, I'll tell another one, OK?
不止一个，但我讲我喜欢的那个，如果你不喜欢，我再讲另一个，好吗？
OK.
好的。
So one day when she left the ghetto on some smuggling mission, she took her little backpack. You know, she would usually get bread and then put it in the backpack. And as she was walking in the streets of Warsaw, a German soldier grabbed her empty backpack. And when she came to take it from him, he just kind of threw it to another soldier.
有天她去执行某种走私任务离开犹太区时，带着她的小背包。通常她会弄到面包，然后放进背包里。当她走在华沙街头时，一个德国士兵抢走了她空的背包。当她去拿回来时，那人随手扔给了另一个士兵。
And they started kind of taunting her, not giving her the bag back. And basically, my mom was about nine years old. Outside of the ghetto, if somebody would catch her, she would be shot on sight as a Jew escaping the ghetto.
他们开始戏弄她，不把包还给她。我妈当时大约九岁。在犹太区外，如果有人抓住她，作为逃离区的犹太人，她会被当场枪决。
And as they were throwing the backpack from one to another, she saw an SS officer. So she ran to the officer and spoke to him politely in German. She said, "Excuse me, Mr. Officer, but can you help me? There are two soldiers here who are disrespect me. And they are not acting the way a soldier should act." And she brought the SS officer with them, and he shouted both those soldiers. And they gave her the backpack.
当他们把背包扔来扔去时，她看到了一名党卫军军官。她跑到军官面前，用德语礼貌地对他说：“打扰一下，长官，你能帮帮我吗？这里有两个士兵不尊重我。他们的行为不像军人该有的样子。”她把那个党卫军军官带了过去，他冲那两个士兵吼叫。他们把背包还给了她。
That's story's just amazing, that she had the presence of mind that young.
那个故事太惊人了，她那么小竟然有那样的机敏。
Yeah, I think the way that she says it, it's kind of like my late grandfather. He trained her. And she would quote all kinds of things that my grandfather would teach her when she was in the ghetto.
是的，我觉得就像她叙述的方式，有点像我已故的外祖父。是他训练了她。她会引用各种外祖父在犹太区时教给她的东西。
So one of the things that she said, people can't look inside you. So they can never know how hungry you are. But if you're dirty, they'll see it in a second. So, for example, she told me that part of her surviving outside of the ghetto was this idea that she made a point of being extremely clean, even when there were no means of being clean.
她说过的一件事是，别人看不到你的内心，所以永远不会知道你有多饥饿。但如果你脏，他们一眼就能看出来。例如，她告诉我，她在犹太区外生存的一部分心得就是坚持要极其干净，即便根本没有清洁的条件。
And all her life, my mother looked like somebody on a Vogue magazine cover, always with makeup and everything in place. It's this idea that you can carry yourself and show your confidence. And if you do that, then the chances that the world will trample you becomes lower.
我母亲一生看起来都像《Vogue》杂志封面人物，总是化着妆，一切都井井有条。这是一种理念：你要保持仪态并展现自信。如果你这样做，世界践踏你的可能性就会降低。
Story number three-- "Fabric." Before I was born, my mother worked in advertising. She invented slogans, produced commercials, and bargained with newspapers over the ad prices. She really loved it, but it was a demanding job, and she wanted to devote as much time as possible to her kids.
第三个故事，《布料》。我出生前，母亲在做广告业。她发明口号，制作商业广告，跟报社商谈广告价格。她真的很热爱这份工作，但这要求很高，她想尽量多花时间陪孩子。
So when I was a baby, she quit and opened a fabric store. It was called Fabric Basement, and it was in a basement with no windows. She chose it because of the location, across the street and a few doors down from our apartment. It was damp, and dark, and a little musty, but everything inside the store was decorated in good taste.
所以当我还是个婴儿时，她辞职开了家布料店。店名叫“布料地下室”，在一个没窗户的地下室里。她选那里是因为地段好，就在我们公寓街对面，走几步就到。那里又潮又暗，还有点发霉，但店里装修得很有品位。
Mom used to take me with her to work every day and put me on the counter in a bassinet. I grew up listening to her stern pronouncements on questions of cleavage and rivets, and closely watching the eager women who entered the dimly-lit basement to search for the perfect fabric and cut for the dress of their dreams.
妈每天都带着我去上班，把我放在柜台上的摇篮里。我在她关于领口和铆钉的严厉言论中长大，密切注视着那些进入昏暗地下室、寻找完美面料和剪裁来打造梦中礼服的渴望女性们。
When I think about it now, I see my mother hoisting heavy rolls of fabric around in that narrow, dank space. I know it was hard work and didn't pay much. But when I was little, the Fabric Basement seemed to me like a sort of secret kingdom, where my mother reigned supreme.
现在回想起来，我看见母亲在那个狭窄阴暗的空间里搬运沉重的布卷。我知道那很辛苦且赚得不多。但在我小时候，布料地下室对我来说就像是一个秘密王国，而母亲是那里的女王。
Her subjects came to her with their hopes and dreams, and she, the Queen Mother, proclaimed which options made them look thinner and which fatter, what was flattering, and what looked cheap. She spoke with no hesitation or excessive politeness, just as a queen should. And the women kept coming to her little side street in Ramat Gan from all over the country so that my mother could flip through the stacks of Burda Magazines that were piled neatly on the counter and select the patterns that would accentuate their advantages and conceal everything else.
她的臣民带着她们的希望和梦想来找她，而她，皇太后，宣布什么样的选择让她们显得更瘦、什么样的更胖，什么样显气质，什么样显廉价。她说话毫不犹豫，也不过分客气，正如一位女王该有的样子。来自全国各地的女性来到拉马特甘她那个小偏街，好让我母亲能翻阅柜台上整齐堆放的《布尔达》杂志，挑选出能突出她们优势、遮盖其余部分的款式。
Not everyone can be beautiful, Mom told me once. But if you make an effort, and you don't give up, you can always be less ugly.
母亲曾告诉我：“并非每个人都能美若天仙。但只要你努力，不放弃，你总能变得不那么丑。”
Story number four-- "Rain Day." It happened 11 years ago. My wife Shira, my son Lev, and I got up at 7:00 AM. Shira was making a tuna fish sandwich for Lev, who had just started first grade. Lev and I stood by the window looking out at the rain. And I explained, in a fatherly tone, he would have to stay home and play with me and mom today instead of going to school, because it was raining.
第四个故事，《雨天》。这事发生在11年前。我妻子希拉、儿子列夫和我早上7点起床。希拉正为刚上一年级的列夫做金枪鱼三明治。列夫和我站在窗前看着外面的雨。我以父亲般的口吻解释说，因为下雨，他今天不用去上学，得待在家里和我还有妈妈玩。
Lev received this news joyfully. Shira, not so much. "What do you mean he's not going to school?" she asked sharply. "It's raining," I replied, pointing outside. "So?" Shira wanted to know. "So when it rains, you don't go to school," I explained. All she could do was repeat my words. "When it rains, you don't go to school?" I nodded. "OK," she said. "And who made that rule?"
列夫很高兴地听到了这个消息。希拉却不然。“什么意思，他不去学校？”她尖锐地问。“下雨了，”我指着外面回答。“那又怎样？”希拉问。“所以下雨时就不去学校了，”我解释道。她只能重复我的话：“下雨时不去学校？”我点头。“好吧，”她说，“这规矩是谁定的？”
We had very few rules when I was growing up. We had to be polite to our parents. We had to give a coin to every homeless person we saw in the street. If someone elderly got on the bus, we had to offer them our seat, and we couldn't go to school on rainy days. The reason, according to my mother, was that, with all due respect for school, they didn't teach anything important enough to be worth getting wet for.
我成长过程中规矩很少。我们要对父母礼貌。我们要给遇到的每个流浪汉硬币。如果老年人上了公交车，我们要让座，而且雨天不用上学。根据我母亲的说法，原因是：尽管尊重学校，但他们没教什么重要到值得淋雨去学的东西。
My mother lost her parents at a very young age, which is why, as she explained to my siblings and me, she never learned how to be a mother. "Girls learn how to be mothers from their own mothers," she said. "Every girl watches her mother to see how she raises children. But I didn't have a mother for long enough to learn everything, which is why I have to improvise now. So if you see me doing something you don't think is that great, you should always tell me."
母亲很小就失去了父母，所以她向我和兄弟姐妹解释说，她从没学会如何做母亲。“女孩从自己的母亲那里学会如何当母亲，”她说，“每个女孩都看着母亲如何抚养孩子。但我没有足够长的母爱时光去学习这一切，这就是为什么现在我不得不即兴发挥。所以如果你看到我做了什么你认为不太好的事情，一定要告诉我。”
I was very pleased to hear my mother say that, and on the few occasions when she imposed a rule or a demand that I found unfair, I always told her, and she really did listen. But as for staying home from school when it rained, I was completely on board with that. Sadly, Shira's childhood wasn't as magical as mine, and Lev had to pay for that. The poor kid grabbed an umbrella and went to school.
听到母亲这么说我很高兴，每当她提出我觉得不公平的规矩或要求时，我总会告诉她，她也确实听了。但关于雨天不去学校这一点，我完全赞成。遗憾的是，希拉的童年不像我的那么神奇，列夫不得不为此买单。那个可怜的孩子抓起雨伞去学校了。
Ira?
艾拉？
Yes, Etgar.
是的，埃特加。
So I was just wondering. This next story, if it's not-- it doesn't feel kind of a bit strange that you get, like, those short pieces, and then suddenly a very long one, and there is no something before it? I don't know, like us talking or music or I don't know.
我只是在想，下一个故事，如果不……是不是感觉有点奇怪，你会有那些短篇，然后突然来了一个很长的，前面什么也没有？我不知道，比如我们谈话或者是音乐之类的。
Well, this could be the thing that goes before it, this thing that you're saying right now.
嗯，这就可以是它前面的东西，就是你现在说的这个。
Nah, I don't know. You're the radio guy, if you think it will work.
不，不知道。你是广播专家，如果你觉得行得通的话。
I do. So here is that story.
我觉得可以。那么，讲那个故事吧。
Story number five-- "You Never Forget a Smell." At my elementary school, there were always fights, and that was just fine with me. It was routine.
第五个故事，《你永远不会忘记那个味道》。在小学，总是有架打，对我来说这很正常。这是一种常规。
The fights always followed the same pattern-- first cursing, then pushing, then choking and kicking until one of the kids yelled uncle. And then it was over. Everyone would head to the corner store for a chocolate milk or a Popsicle like nothing had happened. In other words, no one in school was ever afraid of a little fist fighting. But everyone, even the strongest, meanest kids, was afraid to get in a fight with Tamir.
打架总是一样的模式——先咒骂，然后推搡，接着掐脖子和踢踹，直到其中一个孩子认输。然后就结束了。每个人都会像什么都没发生一样去拐角的商店买巧克力牛奶或冰棍。换句话说，学校里没人怕拳脚架。但每个人，即使是最强壮、最凶狠的孩子，都怕跟塔米尔打架。
Tamir was a year ahead of me. He wasn't big, and he wasn't very muscular either. But whenever he got into a fight with someone in the schoolyard, all the kids who gathered to watch were overcome by a terrible sense of despair, because they knew a fight with Tamir never ended with chocolate milk and a Popsicle at the corner store. Best case scenario, Tamir won, and someone ended up in the emergency room. Worst case, he lost, and the fight went on forever.
塔米尔比我高一级。他个子不大，肌肉也不发达。但每当他在操场上跟人打架时，围观的孩子都会被一种可怕的绝望感笼罩，因为他们知道塔米尔的架从来不会在拐角商店买完冰棍就结束。最好的情况是塔米尔赢了，某人进了急诊室。最坏的情况是输了，打架没完没了。
Not a single kid at school ever saw him surrender. Kids much taller than him, who were already shaving, could pin him to the ground for hours, hurt him, humiliate him, feed him sand, but Tamir would still be cursing and making threats. As the fight wore on, we all knew that no matter how plainly and painfully the other kid was winning, the second he let go, Tamir would be up in a shot and chasing him down with a rock, a metal rod, or whatever weapon he could find. If a teacher or another grownup tried to intervene, they'd get clobbered, too. Bottom line, if anyone had asked me when I was 10 years old what I was most afraid of in the world, I definitely would have said Tamir.
学校里从没有孩子见过他投降。比他高得多、已经开始刮胡子的孩子，可以把他按在地上几个小时，伤害他、羞辱他、把沙子塞进他嘴里，但塔米尔依然会咒骂和威胁。随着打架继续，我们都知道无论对方赢得多明显、多痛苦，只要对方一松手，塔米尔就会立刻跳起来，拿着石头、金属棍或任何能找到的武器追杀他。如果有老师或其他大人试图干预，他们也会挨打。总之，如果我10岁时有人问我最怕世界上什么，我绝对会说是塔米尔。
Every Wednesday after school, I would meet my mother at the grocery store and help her carry the bags home. She would wait outside the store dressed like a queen, in a dress or trendy suit. She always wore lipstick that matched the color of her dress or scarf, and a fashionable hat perched on her head like a crown. As I walked along a busy dirty Bialik Street beside her, loaded with grocery bags, I thought she looked like a stubborn Cinderella, one who insisted on remaining a princess, even after the clock struck midnight and everything turned back into a pumpkin.
每周三放学后，我会在杂货店见母亲，帮她把袋子提回家。她会像女王一样等在店外，穿着连衣裙或时髦套装。她总是抹着与裙子或围巾颜色相配的口红，一顶时髦的帽子戴在头上，像王冠一样。当我装满购物袋，走在她身边那条繁忙又肮脏的比亚利克街上时，我觉得她像个倔强的灰姑娘，即便时钟敲过午夜一切变回南瓜，她也坚持要做公主。
Our apartment building was at the top of a hill, and I always got sweaty and out of breath on the way up with all the groceries. Sometimes I asked for a rest stop, which mom would use to smoke a cigarette.
我们公寓楼在山顶，我带着那些杂货上坡时总是气喘吁吁，满头大汗。有时我会要求休息，母亲就会利用这点停下来抽根烟。
One day, on a break, we heard a strange howl. It sounded like a cat's yelp mixed with a human sob. The second my mother heard this peculiar sound, she tossed her cigarette on the sidewalk, and started quickly marching uphill in the direction the noise was coming from. I picked up all the bags of groceries and tried to keep up with her.
有一天休息时，我们听到一阵奇怪的哀嚎。听起来像猫的惨叫混杂着人的抽泣。母亲听到这奇怪声音的瞬间，把烟头扔在人行道上，快速朝声音传来的方向上坡走去。我提起所有购物袋，试图跟上她。
Before I'd even reached our building, I could see Tamir standing on the sidewalk, waving a stick over his head. At his feet lay Yaki, a boy from my class who lived across the street from us. And when Tamir thumped him on the back with the stick, Yaki whimpered. He barely moved.
甚至还没到我们楼下，我就看到塔米尔站在人行道上，手里挥舞着一根棍子。他脚下躺着我班上的同学亚基，他住我们对面。当塔米尔用棍子重击亚基的背时，亚基发出了呜咽声，几乎动弹不得。
I was completely paralyzed, but not my mother. She marched over quickly on her stilettos. Tamir ignored her and landed another blow on Yaki's back. My mother grabbed Tamir's the arm with one hand and his hair with the other. Tamir tried to wriggle out of her grip, swearing and blustering. "Let me go," he screamed. "Let me go right now. I'll fuck you up, you bitch."
我彻底瘫痪了，但我母亲没有。她踩着高跟鞋快速走过去。塔米尔没理她，又在亚基背上狠狠敲了一下。母亲一只手抓住塔米尔的手臂，另一只手揪住他的头发。塔米尔试图挣脱，骂骂咧咧，叫嚣着：“放开我，”他尖叫，“现在就放开。我要干掉你，臭婊子。”
Terrified, I looked at my mother. She didn't seem to understand who she was dealing with. I'd seen Tamir stab a teacher with a compass and throw a brick at the principal, and I knew exactly how this would end. My mother would eventually have to let go, and then all hell would break loose.
我惊恐地看着母亲。她似乎不知道自己在跟什么样的人打交道。我见过塔米尔用圆规捅老师，把砖头扔向校长，我知道这会怎么收场。我母亲最终不得不放手，然后所有地狱之火都会烧开。
I wanted to say something, to warn her. But I didn't know exactly what to tell her. The only good advice I could give her about Tamir was not to mess with him. But it was too late for that.
我想说点什么来提醒她。但我不知道该说什么。关于塔米尔，我能给她的唯一好建议就是别惹他。但现在太晚了。
Mom twisted Tamir's arm behind his back, which made him drop the stick. Yaki was still on the ground. "Just wait, you bitch," Tamir hissed. "I'll tear you a new one."
妈把塔米尔的手臂扭到背后，让他扔掉了棍子。亚基依然趴在地上。“等着瞧，臭婊子，”塔米尔嘶吼，“我会把你撕成碎片。”
My mother looked at him coldly, and signaled for me to come closer. I moved towards him, dragging the grocery bags, and stopped the few steps away. That seemed close enough. But Mom beckoned me to come closer.
母亲冷冷地看着他，示意我靠近。我拖着杂货袋走过去，在几步外停下。这看起来足够近了。但妈招手让我再靠近点。
"It's all right," she said in a reassuring voice. "Don't be afraid. He won't bite." I took a few more steps, until I was standing within spitting distance of Tamir's sweaty face. "Leave me alone," he screeched. "Let me go or I'll whack you." "Shh," Mom said, still using a soothing voice. "In a minute, as soon as you listen to what I have to say."
“没关系，”她用安慰的语调说，“别怕。他不会咬人的。”我又走了几步，直到站在离塔米尔汗津津的脸只有吐沫星子距离的地方。“离我远点，”他尖叫，“放开我，否则我就揍你。”“嘘，”妈依然用安抚的语调说，“再过一分钟，只要你听我说完。”
Tamir stopped talking and turned to my mother with an expectant look. "Do you see this boy?" my mother asked, and she held Tamir's face close to mine. "This is my son. Now, take a deep sniff. Good. You never forget a smell."
塔米尔停止了叫嚣，期待地看着我母亲。“看到这个男孩了吗？”我母亲问，把塔米尔的脸拉近我，“这是我儿子。现在，深深地吸口气。很好。你永远不会忘记那个味道。”
Tamir's face was barely an inch away from mine. I was so close that I could see the blood vessels in the whites of his eyes as he gave me a menacing look. "And this," Mom said, turning Tamir's head towards Yaki, who managed to sit up on his knees, "is his friend, Yaki. As far as I'm concerned, this whole neighborhood is yours, except these two. You can hit, bite, stab, steal-- anything you like. But if you so much as touch them--"
塔米尔的脸离我的脸只有一英寸远。离得那么近，我都能看到他布满红血丝的眼白，他给了我一个充满威胁的眼神。“还有这个，”妈转过塔米尔的头，看向亚基，亚基努力用膝盖撑起身子，“这是他的朋友亚基。在我看来，整个街区都是你的，除了这两个人。你可以打、咬、捅、偷——随便你。但如果你敢动他们一根手指……”
"If I touch them, then what?" Tamir said with a chilling smile. "You'll call the cops? I've had the cops called on me 10 times." "Oh, the police, God forbid," Mom said. "They have more important things to worry about." She dragged Tamir over to the big dumpster next to our building.
“如果我动了，会怎样？”塔米尔带着令人毛骨悚然的微笑说，“报警？警察都被叫来找我10次了。”“噢，报警，上帝禁止，”妈说，“他们有更重要的事情要担心。”她把塔米尔拖到我们楼旁边的大垃圾箱旁。
"If you touch my son or Yaki, I'll kill you, and then I'll throw your body into this trash can." She was pulling Tamir's hair now, making him look right into the dumpster. "And the next morning, a truck will come and remove your body with the trash, and bury it far, far away. And no one will even come looking for you or try to find out what happened, because no one will miss you."
“如果你动我儿子或亚基，我就杀了你，然后把你的尸体扔进这个垃圾桶。”她此时正揪着塔米尔的头发，让他直视垃圾箱，“第二天早上，垃圾车会来把你的身体连同垃圾一起运走，埋到很远很远的地方。没人会来找你，或者试图找出发生了什么，因为没人会想念你。”
As a child, you quickly learn to identify when your parents are making empty threats and when they mean what they say. Mom's tone-- detached, almost bored-- was her ordinary voice, the one I recognized from conversations with the ladies at her fabric shop, or people she ran into on the street. And so within seconds, I stopped being scared that Tamir would break free and beat us up and started being scared that he'd die.
小时候，你很快就能学会辨别父母是在空口威胁，还是言出必行。妈的语调——冷漠、近乎无聊——那是她的日常声音，我从她与布料店女士的谈话，或是街上遇到的人的谈话中认得这种语气。所以几秒钟内，我停止了担心塔米尔会挣脱并痛打我们，开始担心他真的会死。
My mom put her face right up to Tamir's, and he looked at her, wide-eyed. "You might be a bully, Tamir, but you're not stupid. Now, I want you to look at me very closely, and tell me whether I'm lying or if it's really going to happen."
我妈把脸贴在塔米尔脸上，他睁大眼睛看着她。“你也许是个恶霸，塔米尔，但你不蠢。现在，我要你仔细看着我，告诉我我在撒谎，还是这些真的会发生。”
Tamir kept staring at my mother as if he were hypnotized. And after a pause, he said, almost in a whisper, "I promise you, Mrs. Keret. I'll never touch them." "Very good," said Mom, and let go of him. "I knew you were a smart boy."
塔米尔盯着我母亲，仿佛被催眠了一样。停顿片刻后，他几乎是在低语：“我向你保证，凯雷特太太。我永远不会动他们。”“很好，”妈说，松开了他，“我就知道你是个聪明的男孩。”
They stood facing each other for some time, a 12-year-old boy in a school uniform and a little woman in a red dress and high heels. Mom slowly lifted her hand and caressed Tamir's sweaty hair. "Very good," she repeated softly. "Now that we're clear on everything, you should go home. It will be dark soon, and it's getting cold."
他们互相面对着站了一会儿，一个穿着校服的12岁男孩和一个穿着红裙子、高跟鞋的小女人。妈慢慢抬起手，抚摸了塔米尔汗湿的头发。“很好，”她轻声重复，“既然我们说清楚了，你应该回家了。天很快就黑了，天也冷了。”
Etgar?
埃特加？
Yes.
在。
I think all the stories that you've told so far, your mom is the hero. And I wonder, are there stories where you felt embarrassed for her, or she embarrassed you, or she isn't the hero in that way?
我觉得到目前为止你讲的所有故事里，你母亲都是英雄。我在想，有没有让你觉得为她尴尬，或者她让你尴尬，或者她并不是那种英雄的故事？
Well, first of all, I think that she was inherently the hero in fighting for things. But I can say that sometimes she would protect her loved ones a little bit too much.
嗯，首先，我觉得她在为某些事情战斗时本身就是英雄。但我可以说，有时她保护她所爱的人稍微过度了一些。
I remember that when my father was dying from cancer, he had a room all alone in the hospital. And my dad was a heavy smoker. He died from smoker's cancer. And he used to smoke in this room. And you're not allowed to smoke in the hospital.
记得我父亲癌症去世时，他在医院有一个单独的房间。我爸爸是个烟鬼，他死于吸烟引起的癌症。他过去常在房间里抽烟。医院是不允许抽烟的。
And I remember one time that a woman kind of entered the room, and she said, "Is somebody smoking here? Because I can smell smoke." And my mom said, "No. I can't smell anything." And the woman left the room and returned after five minutes. And she said, "I'm sure that somebody is smoking here." And my mom said, "I don't know, I don't see anybody smoking. How are you so sure?"
我记得有一次，一个女人进了房间，她说：“有人在这里抽烟吗？因为我闻到了烟味。”我妈说：“没有。我什么也没闻到。”那个女人离开房间，五分钟后又回来了，她说：“我确定有人在这里抽烟。”我妈说：“不知道，我没看到有人在抽烟。你怎么这么确定？”
And the woman left. And then she returned a third time, and she said, "Don't lie to me. I know that there is somebody smoking in this room." And my mom looked at her with ice-cold eyes and said to her, in English, "Go to hell," and kind of slammed the door in her face. And you know, I was there, and it was very embarrassing. The woman never opened the door again.
那个女人走了，然后她第三次回来，说：“别对我撒谎。我知道房间里有人抽烟。”我妈冰冷地看着她，用英语说：“去地狱吧”，然后砰地一声把门关在她脸上。你知道，我就在旁边，当时非常尴尬。那个女人再也没打开过那扇门。
But it was embarrassing.
但这很尴尬。
It was very embarrassing, you know? I mean, I think that my mom many times overreacted.
非常尴尬，你知道吗？我是说，我觉得我妈很多时候反应过度了。
I get that. But I'll just point out that I asked you for a story where she's not the hero. And in this story, she's still the hero.
我明白。但我只是想指出，我问你要一个她不是英雄的故事。而在那个故事里，她依然是英雄。
Yeah, you're right. You're right. But I think that also, it's something that had to do with her charisma. I mean, hero, villain, we can argue about it. But she was the main character. She was smack there in the center.
是的，你说得对。你说得对。但我认为，这也是由于她的个人魅力。我是说，英雄还是恶棍，我们可以争论。但她是主角。她就在那里，处于中心位置。
Let's say if we would wait for a doctor, and there would be like 20 people in the hall, then I would say 4 out of 5 times, before we'd get to the doctor, they would kind of gather around my mother. And she would tell them, I'll tell you what you should tell your wife. Come here, sit next to me. I'll explain to you, oh, what they shouldn't eat for dinner. But she would become this instant guru.
比方说如果我们等医生，大厅里有20个人，我会说5次里有4次，在见到医生之前，他们会聚集在我母亲周围。她会告诉他们：我告诉你你应该跟你妻子说什么。过来，坐我旁边。我会解释给你听，噢，他们晚餐不应该吃什么。她成了即时的导师。
Guru, yeah.
导师，是啊。
She kind of projected this feeling that if you follow her, you get somewhere good.
她投射出一种感觉，如果你跟随她，你就能走向好的地方。
OK, so Etgar, we have to get to the station break-- the ID break now.
好的，埃特加，我们必须进入电台停顿了——身份识别停顿。
What do you do on ID breaks?
你们在身份识别停顿的时候做什么？
Well, it's like a minute that we give to the radio stations to do their local stuff.
嗯，这大约是一分钟的时间，留给电台去处理他们的本地事务。
And what do we do during that break?
那我们在停顿时做什么？
Oh, we just hang out here for one minute.
噢，我们就在这里待一分钟。
Cool.
酷。
OK. OK, and then do you want to read the wording that gets us into the ID break?
好的。好的，那你想读出带我们进入身份识别停顿的词吗？
Yeah, yeah. Of course. I do it now?
是的，是的。当然，我现在读吗？
Yes, now.
是的，现在。
I thought you were going to say something. OK, sorry. Sorry. I'm doing it. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
我以为你会说点什么的。好的，抱歉。抱歉。我在做。一分钟后回来，当我们的节目继续时，来自芝加哥公共广播电台。
It's "This American Life." I'm Ira Glass. Today's program is this thing that Etgar Keret and I concocted, that we're calling "Half-Baked Stories About My Dead Mom," where Etgar is trying to create a picture of his mother, Orna, through these fragments of memory-- eight very short stories that he's written about her, plus some conversations.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目是埃特加·凯雷特和我构思的内容，我们称之为“关于我亡母的半成品故事”，埃特加正试图通过这些记忆碎片——他写的八个关于母亲奥娜的极短故事，加上一些对话，来勾勒他母亲的形象。
Some basic facts about his mom's life, before we go any further in this hour. After her time in a Polish orphanage and some time in Czechoslovakia and France, she arrived in Israel as a teenager on a ship whose Hebrew name roughly translates to "don't mess with us," or "you will not threaten us," which Etgar says is the perfect name for the boat that his mother would arrive on.
在我们深入这一小时之前，关于他母亲生活的一些基本事实。在她度过波兰孤儿院以及在捷克斯洛伐克和法国的时间后，她以十几岁的年龄乘坐一艘希伯来语名字翻译过来大约是“别惹我们”或“你不会威胁我们”的船来到以色列，埃特加说这对母亲乘坐的船来说是个完美的名字。
At 18 or so, she married a professional soccer player and divorced him a few months later. Went to live in France for a year or so. She was an incredible dancer, won dance competitions. Danced once with the singer Jacques Brel.
大约18岁时，她嫁给了一位职业足球运动员，几个月后就离婚了。去了法国住了一年左右。她是一个不可思议的舞者，赢得过舞蹈比赛。曾与歌手雅克·布雷尔共舞过。
The way she met Etgar's dad, he was drunk and peed on the French embassy, not knowing it was the French embassy. Cops thought it was a political statement, threw him in a squad car and ran off to get the guys he was with. Etgar's dad saw his mom walking down the street, just walking by at that moment, and wanted to meet her.
她遇见埃特加父亲的方式是，他当时喝醉了，在法国大使馆撒尿，不知道那是法国大使馆。警察以为那是政治声明，把他扔进警车，跑去抓他同伴了。埃特加的父亲看到我母亲正走在街上，当时正巧路过，就想认识她。
So he stepped out of the police car and introduced himself as Inspector Keret. And he asked her if she saw anything that happened. She said, no, I just got here. So he said, I need to get your details anyway. And he took her address and the phone number.
于是他走出警车，自我介绍说是凯雷特警督。他问她有没有看到刚才发生的事。她说，没有，我刚到。他说，无论如何我需要你的联系方式。于是他拿到了她的地址和电话。
And then the police came back, and they handcuffed my father and got him back in the police car. And my mom went back to a flatmate, and she said, "That's just my luck. I gave my phone number to a serial killer."
然后警察回来了，他们给我父亲戴上手铐，带回了警车。我妈回到室友那里，说：“这就是我的运气。我把电话号码给了个连环杀手。”
When Etgar's dad sobered up, he had a hard time actually convincing her that he was not a criminal of some sort. They were a good match. Both had been children in Poland during the war so, Etgar says, neither of them had any idea what a normal childhood or a normal home would be.
当埃特加的父亲清醒后，他费了很大力气才让她相信他不是那种罪犯。他们很般配。两人小时候都在战时的波兰长大，所以埃特加说，他们俩根本不知道什么是正常的童年或正常的家庭。
So there was something in their friendship that it was half like a married couple, but it was also half like kindergarten children playing together. And I think that the kindergarten part seemed much more powerful than the grownup part.
所以他们的友谊中有某种东西，一半像一对夫妻，另一半像一起玩的幼儿园孩子。我觉得幼儿园那部分似乎比成年那部分更强大。
After his mom died, Etgar found that she had kept all the little notes that his father had written her over the years, going back a half century. Most of them were things like, "We're out of milk. Can you pick some up?" Or "I'll be home at 9:00, not 8:00." She seemed to have saved every one.
母亲去世后，埃特加发现她保留了父亲多年来写给她的所有小纸条，可以追溯到半个世纪前。大多数内容都是像：“牛奶没了。你能去买点吗？”或“我9点到家，不是8点。”她似乎存下了每一张。
Story number six-- "The Stuff." For my fifth birthday, my father took me to see Bambi. The movie was a lot more real than anything I'd seen. And when the hunters shot and killed Bambi's mom, I stood up on my seat in the movie theater and started shouting tearfully about how wrong this turn of events was, and demanded they stop showing the film immediately.
第六个故事，《东西》。五岁生日时，父亲带我去看《小鹿斑比》。这部电影比我见过的任何东西都真实。当猎人开枪打死斑比的妈妈时，我在电影院座位上站起来，泪流满面地大喊这种事态的发展有多错误，并要求他们立即停止放映。
My father was slightly embarrassed by my display. "Why are you crying?" my dad asked. "What's wrong?" "They killed Bambi's mom for no reason," I cried. Desperate to calm me down, my dad replied, "No, no. There is a reason. They're going to make a yummy schnitzel out of her." And just like that, on the day I turned five, I became a vegetarian.
父亲对我这种表现感到有点尴尬。“你为什么哭？”爸爸问，“怎么了？”“他们无缘无故杀了斑比的妈妈，”我哭着说。为了让我冷静下来，爸爸绝望地回答：“不，不。是有原因的。他们要把她做成美味的炸肉排。”就这样，在我五岁生日那天，我成了素食者。
Israel in the early '70s wasn't exactly a nation of vegans. When my mom realized that her pint-sized boy was losing weight, she swung into action. "You hardly eat anything," she sighed after dinner one night. "But that's fine. If you don't like the food you've tried, I'll just have to invent something new for you." And that was how The Stuff was born.
70年代初的以色列并不是严格的纯素食国家。当母亲意识到她那小不点儿子正在变瘦时，她采取了行动。“你几乎什么都不吃，”晚饭后的一天晚上她叹了口气，“但这没关系。如果你不喜欢你尝过的食物，我只能为你发明一些新东西。”就这样，《东西》诞生了。
The Stuff was made of dried, shriveled up soybean flakes that looked a bit like pet kibble. My mom got ahold of the soy flakes from a vegan rabbi in Jerusalem, to whom she was introduced by the American sales clerk at a natural food store on the outskirts of Ramat Gan. The soy flakes had the texture of pigeon droppings and no flavor whatsoever. But when mixed with my mother's culinary charisma, as well as tomato paste, garlic, carrots, a secret ingredient or two, and lots of water, they were transformed into the legendary Stuff, the ambrosia from which my mom could make meatballs, hamburgers, and even no-lognese, a delicious vegetarian substitute for Bolognese sauce.
《东西》是由干缩的豆子片制成的，看起来有点像宠物粮。妈从耶路撒冷的一位素食拉比那里弄到了豆子片，是通过拉马特甘郊区一家天然食品店的美国店员介绍认识的。豆子片口感像鸽子屎，完全没味儿。但在母亲烹饪魅力的混合下，加上番茄酱、大蒜、胡萝卜，还有一两种秘制成分和大量的水，它们变成了传说中的《东西》，那是母亲可以用来做肉丸、汉堡甚至无肉肉酱——一种美味的肉酱面素食替代品的仙露。
Rumor traveled fast about The Stuff. One day, a boy I didn't know, who was at least a year older than me, introduced himself and asked if what they said about my mother was true. Could she really make food that tasted like hamburger, pizza, and rubber, all at the same time? I nodded yes.
关于《东西》的传言传得很快。一天，一个我不认识的、至少比我大一岁的男孩自我介绍，问关于我母亲的传言是否属实。她真的能做出尝起来像汉堡、比萨饼和橡胶，却又同时具备这三种味道的食物吗？我点了点头。
"If you can set me up with some, I'll give you five liras," the kid said. To make sure I understood this was a serious offer, he pulled out the appropriate bill-- green with a portrait of Albert Einstein. It was a bizarre situation, and I wasn't really sure what to say.
“如果你能帮我搞到一些，我给你五里拉，”那孩子说。为了确保我明白这是严肃的提议，他拿出了一张绿色的纸币，上面印着阿尔伯特·爱因斯坦的肖像。这情况很离奇，我真不知道该说什么。
"I'll come over some day," the kid suggested. "Tell your mom we're friends or something, or that I'm helping you with your homework. And then I'll stay for dinner." I still said nothing. "Come on," he nudged me. "Help me out, seriously. Pizza, hamburger, and rubber together? I have to try."
“我哪天过来，”那孩子提议，“告诉妈我们是朋友或者什么，或者说你在帮我做作业。然后我留下来吃晚餐。”我依然没说话。“来吧，”他推我，“帮帮我，说真的。比萨、汉堡和橡胶放在一起？我一定要尝尝。”
Of course he felt that way. It's not every day you have a chance to eat something extraordinary, something that only one unique woman could invent. The Walter White of our neighborhood, my mother.
当然他会有这种感觉。并不是每天你都有机会吃到非同寻常的东西，某种只有一位独特女性才能发明出来的东西。我们街区的沃尔特·怀特，我的母亲。
Ira?
艾拉？
Yes, Etgar.
是的，埃特加。
Ira?
艾拉？
Yes, Etgar.
是的，埃特加。
I have this story I've got to tell you. It has nothing to do with it, but it's just that I want to tell you the story. So I'm-- OK.
我有这个故事必须告诉你。它与此无关，但我只是想讲给你听。所以我是——好的。
OK.
好的。
It's like I tried to write down this story. And the story is that about a year before my mother died, I came to visit her. And she was in her bed in the bedroom. And I was sitting next to her. And then she said, "Could you please close the door? I want to say something private." And it was very weird, because it was only the two of us in the apartment. So I said, "It must be something very, very secretive if you need to close the door."
我试着写下这个故事。故事是这样的，在我母亲去世前约一年，我去探望她。她躺在卧室的床上。我坐在她旁边。然后她说：“你能关上门吗？我想说些私人的话。”这很奇怪，因为公寓里只有我们两个。所以我说：“如果需要关上门，那肯定是非常非常秘密的事情。”
And I closed the door, and I sat down. And she said, "Look, I want to ask you a favor. You know, now that Dad, Father is gone, and I see that I'm kind of beginning to lose my lucidity a little-- so if you see that you know that I'm totally not lucid, and if you have some kinds of sensations that are not happy, then you just wait until I'm asleep. And then you take a pillow, and put it on my face. And, you know, just kind of gently wait a little bit. In one minute, I'm gone with all my smoking and stuff. So I just want to ask you if-- I hope it's OK."
我关上门，坐了下来。她说：“看，我想求你个恩情。你知道，既然爸——父亲走了，我发现我有点开始失去理智了——所以如果你看到我完全失去理智，如果你有某些不愉快的感觉，你就等我睡着了。然后拿一个枕头，放在我脸上。然后，你知道，轻轻等一会儿。一分钟内，我就带着我所有的吸烟和那些东西走了。所以我只是想问你是否——希望这没问题。”
And I was kind of shaken. I was a little bit frozen. And then she looked at me. And she said, "Look." It's as if she-- like, "I didn't want to bother you, but, you know, your sister is ultra-Orthodox. She can't do that. And your brother, he has such a big heart. He's soft. You're the strongest. You're the strong guy."
我当时被震住了，有点僵住。然后她看着我。她说：“看。”这就像她——她说：“我不想打扰你，但是，你知道，你妹妹是极端正统派。她做不到。而你弟弟，他心太软了。他很柔弱。你是最强的。你是那个坚强的人。”
And I said to her, "Mom, I'm not that strong." And then she looked at me, and she smiled. And she said, "You are, but it doesn't matter. You want to have a cake?" And then we got up, and she gave me cake, and we drank tea, and we talked. And she smiled. And we had the nicest conversation, and we hugged.
我说：“妈，我没那么坚强。”然后她看着我，笑了笑。她说：“你是，但这不重要。你想吃蛋糕吗？”然后我们起来，她给了我蛋糕，我们喝了茶，聊了天。她笑了。我们进行了最愉快的谈话，我们拥抱了。
And basically, when I wrote this story down, I remember this story as kind of a very close moment with my mother. But it wasn't filed under my mother asking me to murder her, you know? It was basically my mom, a little bit afraid, wants me to do something. Then she sees I'm unhappy about it, and in a second, she doesn't care anymore what's good for her. She'll die demented, and she did die demented. But she will not put me in a position. She said to me, "I wouldn't want you to do something that you feel uncomfortable about."
基本上，当我写下这个故事时，我记得这个故事像是与母亲的一次非常亲密的时刻。但这并没有归类在我母亲请求我谋杀她的档案里，你知道吗？基本上是我妈，有点害怕，想让我做点什么。然后她看到我对这件事不高兴，在一秒钟内，她就不再在乎什么对她好了。她会死于痴呆，她确实死于痴呆。但她绝不会把我置于那个处境。她对我说：“我不想让你做任何你觉得不舒服的事情。”
She said that to you in that conversation.
她在那个谈话中对你这么说了？
Yeah, she said-- when I said to her, "I can't put a pillow on your head." And she said, "Why?" And I said, "I can't." And she said, "Look, I don't want you to do anything that you are uncomfortable about."
是的，她说——当我对她说：“我不能把枕头放在你头上。”她说：“为什么？”我说：“我做不到。”她说：“看，我不希望你做任何让你不舒服的事情。”
And this idea was really that reality could be harsh, violent. I could kill my mom. I could not kill my mom. But there is another level, and this is a level of two human beings who are close to each other, who can ask each other for everything, who can say no to everything, who doesn't feel uncomfortable. There is no egos there. So it was, for me, some kind of a mirror of a healthy relationship.
这个理念真的是现实可能很严酷、暴力。我可以杀了我妈。我可以不杀我妈。但还有另一个层面，这就是两个亲近的人之间的层面，他们可以互相请求一切，可以拒绝一切，不会感到不舒服。这里没有自负。所以对我来说，这是某种健康关系的镜像。
Story number seven-- "The First Angel You See." I only ever heard this story once. My parents had just come home from a wedding, and my mother was completely drunk. If she'd had one less drink that night, I probably wouldn't be able to share this story with you.
第七个故事，《你见到的第一个天使》。这个故事我只听过一次。我父母刚从一场婚礼回来，我母亲喝得酩酊大醉。如果那天晚上她少喝一杯，我可能就没法和你分享这个故事了。
It's a little hazy in my imagination, but in the story, my mom is little. It's during the war, and her mother, my grandmother, is holding her hand while carrying mom's baby brother. And the three of them race up the stairs in some building.
在我的想象中有点模糊，但在故事里，我妈还是个小女孩。那是在战争期间，她的母亲，也就是我的外祖母，牵着她的手，抱着我妈那还是婴儿的弟弟。他们三个冲上某栋建筑的楼梯。
Mom can hear the footsteps of the people chasing them. When they get to the rooftop, my grandmother tells Mom to run as fast as she can and jump down to the roof of the next building, which is slightly lower. "Don't be scared," she says. "You can do it."
妈妈能听到后面追赶他们的人的脚步声。当他们到达楼顶时，外祖母告诉妈尽可能快地跑，跳到下一栋建筑的屋顶，那里稍微低一点。“别怕，”她说，“你能行。”
Mom waits, expecting her mother to say, "And I'll be right behind you." But she just stands there out of breath from the run. "When will I see you again?" my mother asks. And her mother bends over so their faces are very close, and says, "You're going to run as fast as you can, and then jump as far as you can. And as soon as you land, you're going to keep running and not stop until you get to Daddy. After that, you grow up into a woman, and will meet a man and fall in love, and start a family with him. And in the end, you grow old and die.
妈等着，期待着母亲会说：“我会紧跟着你。”但她只是气喘吁吁地站在那儿。“我什么时候能再见到你？”我母亲问。她母亲弯下腰，让她们的脸靠得很近，说：“你会跑得尽可能快，然后跳得尽可能远。一旦你着地，你就要继续跑，直到找到爸爸。在那之后，你会长大成女人，遇见一个男人并坠入爱河，和他组建家庭。最后，你会变老并死去。”
And right after you die, go up to the first angel you see, and tell him, 'I'm going to see my mom.' And he'll know, because I'll talk to him before you get there. And he'll bring you to me."
“就在你死后，走到你见到的第一个天使面前，对他说：‘我要见我妈妈。’他会知道的，因为在你到达之前我会先跟他说。他会带你来见我。”
This is not where the story ends. After my mom jumped onto the other roof, she didn't run as fast as she could, the way her mother had instructed her. Instead, she hid and watched the Nazi soldiers kill her mother and smash her little brother's head against a brick wall. When she told me this, I could feel her guilt, but I also sensed how proud she was of her mother, who, even in the last moments of her life, refused to lie to her daughter.
这不是故事的结局。在我妈跳到另一个屋顶后，她没有像母亲嘱咐的那样拼命奔跑，相反，她躲了起来，看着纳粹士兵杀害了她母亲，把她弟弟的头撞在砖墙上。当我妈告诉我这些时，我能感觉到她的内疚，但我也感受到她对母亲的自豪，她即便在生命的最后时刻，也拒绝向女儿撒谎。
47 years after she told me this story, my mother died. And the last words she said to me were, "I'm going to see my mom."
在她告诉我这个故事47年后，我母亲去世了。她对我说的最后一句话是：“我要见我妈妈。”
Story number eight-- "A Good Day." When I was a kid, I absolutely loved eating at restaurants. In those days, in socialist Israel of the 1970s, going out for dinner was such a rare and decadent event that it was impossible not to get excited about it.
第八个故事，《美好的一天》。小时候，我非常喜欢在餐馆吃饭。在那个70年代社会主义的以色列，出去吃顿晚餐是一件罕见且奢侈的事，让人无法不为此激动。
Once every few months, we'd drive to Victor's Place, a Tel Aviv eatery located next to a junkyard. After dinner, while Mom and Dad sipped Turkish coffee and smoked a cigarette, my brother would take my sister and me on an exciting tour of the junkyard, which we called the car cemetery. We'd stop at each crumpled vehicle and try to guess how it had ended up there-- trampled by an elephant, shot out of a cannon, or just driven too quickly and rammed into a stoplight.
每几个月一次，我们会开车去维克多餐厅，那是一家位于垃圾场旁边的特拉维夫餐馆。晚餐后，当爸妈抿着土耳其咖啡抽烟时，哥哥会带我和姐姐去垃圾场进行激动人心的游览，我们称之为“汽车墓地”。我们会停在每辆撞得扭曲的车辆旁，猜测它是怎么落到那里的——被大象踩扁的、从大炮里打出来的，或者只是开太快撞到了红绿灯。
One Saturday, when I was about six, we went to Victor's Place for my mother's birthday. The waiter was an older man with a mustache, and he informed us apologetically that, due to a kitchen malfunction, the restaurant would not be serving fries. The rest of the family received this news with indifference, but I took it really hard. Instead of a big pile of delicious, greasy fries, the waiter put a dish of white rice on the table-- white rice. And within seconds, the lavish feast I'd been looking forward to for weeks turned into just another family dinner.
一个周六，我大约六岁时，我们去维克多餐厅给母亲过生日。服务员是个留着胡子的老男人，他带着歉意告诉我们，由于厨房故障，餐馆无法供应炸薯条。家人对这个消息表现得很淡定，但我非常难过。本该有的一大堆美味酥脆的炸薯条没了，服务员在桌上放了一盘白米饭——白米饭。几秒钟内，我期待已久的盛宴变成了又一顿普通的家庭晚餐。
My mother, sensing my frustration, asked me if everything was all right. "Nothing was all right," I snapped. If I couldn't have fries, the whole meal was a waste of time. And this birthday, which was supposed to be fun, was now the worst day of my life.
母亲察觉到我的沮丧，问我是否一切安好。“一点都不安好，”我怒冲冲地说。如果我吃不到薯条，这顿饭简直是浪费时间。而这个本该有趣的生日，现在成了我一生中最糟糕的一天。
Mom listened patiently to my complaints. And when I was done, she put the back of her warm hand on my neck, and asked me, in half a whisper, to tell her how many people were sitting in the restaurant. Being a good boy, I methodically counted them all. Saturday afternoon was one of the busiest times at Victor's. And besides our table, there were 26 diners.
母亲耐心地听我抱怨。当我发泄完，她把温暖的手背放在我脖子上，半低声地请求我告诉她餐馆里坐了多少人。作为一个乖孩子，我按部就班地数了数。周六下午是维克多最忙的时段。除我们这桌外，有26位食客。
"26!" my mom exclaimed with a whistle. "That's a lot. Now, could you please tell me what all these people are holding in their hands?" "Oh, come on," I said with a grin. "That's easy. It's a restaurant. They're holding knives and forks."
“26个！”妈吹着口哨惊呼，“那很多。现在，你能告诉我这些人手里都拿着什么吗？”“噢，算了吧，”我笑着说，“那太简单了。这是餐馆。他们拿着刀叉。”
Mom was impressed. "26 people-- 26 hungry human beings sitting at their tables, each eating only what's on their own plate. 26 people holding knives, and yet not a single one of them is stabbing anyone else." She leaned over, planted a soft kiss on my forehead, and said, "Let's agree that this is a pretty good day."
妈印象深刻。“26个人——26个饥饿的人类坐在餐桌前，每个人只吃盘子里的东西。26个人手里拿着刀，却没有一个人在捅别人。”她俯下身，在我前额轻轻吻了一下，说：“我们达成共识，这真是美好的一天。”
Etgar Keret. Most of the stories today about his mom were originally written for an exhibit about her, called "Inside Out," at the Jewish Museum in Berlin. It runs till March 19.
埃特加·凯雷特。今天关于他母亲的大多数故事最初是为柏林犹太博物馆关于她的展览“由内而外”撰写的。该展览将持续至3月19日。
If you liked these stories today, one of Etgar's books is a book of memoirs, essays like these, called Seven Good Years. And he also sends out a weekly short story in a free Substack newsletter called "Alphabet Soup."
如果你喜欢今天这些故事，埃特加的一本书是回忆录和随笔集，名为《七年》。他还通过名为“字母汤”的免费Substack时事通讯每周发送一篇短篇小说。
Jacques Brel. Etgar says this song was one of his mom's favorites, and she would sing it to him when he was a kid.
雅克·布雷尔。埃特加说这首歌是他母亲的最爱之一，他小时候她常唱给他听。
Well, our program was produced today by me and Elna Baker. The people who put together today's show include Sean Cole, Michael Comite, Chana Joffe-Walt, Valerie Kipnis, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Ryan Rumery, Charlotte Sleeper, Frances Swanson, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu. Our Managing Editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our Senior Editor is David Kestenbaum. Our Executive Editor is Emanuele Berry.
我们的节目今天由我和艾尔娜·贝克制作。参与制作今天节目的包括肖恩·科尔、迈克尔·科米特、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、瓦莱丽·基普尼斯、斯托·尼尔森、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、纳迪亚·雷曼、瑞安·鲁梅里、夏洛特·斯利珀、弗朗西斯·斯旺森、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼、朱莉·惠特克和黛安·吴。我们的执行编辑是莎拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼。我们的高级编辑是大卫·克斯滕鲍姆。我们的执行主编是伊曼纽尔·贝里。
Jessica Cohen translated Etgar's stories into English.
杰西卡·科恩将埃特加的故事翻译成了英语。
Special thanks today to Gal Ber, Nimrod Keret, Lev Keret for technical help, and Chris Crawford. Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 750 episodes for absolutely free. Also, there's videos. There's lists of favorite programs, there's tons of other stuff. Again, ThisAmericanLife.org.
特别感谢今天的加尔·伯尔、尼姆罗德·凯雷特、列夫·凯雷特的帮助，以及克里斯·克劳福德。访问我们的网站ThisAmericanLife.org，您可以完全免费播放我们超过750集的档案。此外，还有视频、最喜爱节目的列表，以及海量其他内容。再次强调，ThisAmericanLife.org。
"This American Life" is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. His New Year's resolution this year? Come up with more zingers. I told him I was having a hard time coming up with my resolution. He piped up right away.
《美国生活》由公共广播交换平台PRX递送至公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚先生。他今年的新年决心是什么？想出更多俏皮话。我告诉他我很难想出决心。他立刻接话道：
You can always be less ugly.
你总能变得不那么丑。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of "This American Life."
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带更多《美国生活》的故事回来。